The couple of other techniques.
In fact the next one we're going to
talked about is hardly used.
A number of operating systems now and so
one thing that's going to be different
about the next two techniques we'll
talked about is that they going to use.
Support from the operating
system/hardware that we have
to deal with buffer overflow or
to thwart buffer overflow attacks.
So the first one, as which I
said many operating systems use,
is what is called
Address Space Layout Randomization.
ASLR.
So remember,
in an address space, some place stack
is space where stack is allocated.
So, stack starts at certain place.
Somewhere the library code goes, another
place where the heap goes, and so on.
What if we randomize the places
where these areas of memory start.
Remember that hacker had to actually
guess where key information is.
So if I wanted to do return to libc
attack, I had to know where the library
is, where a certain function may be, so
I know the address of that function.
And I can use that as I overflow the
return address field in the stack frame.
So, I need to know these address.
And what ASLR does, it makes hard,
because of the randomization that we do,
it makes hard for the attacker to
find these important locations.
Where the address that
the attacker is interested in
is going to over the information,
address of the information that that
hacker is interested in is not know.
So as I said.
A number of operating systems
these days actually do that to
protect the programs and processes from
these buffer overflow kind of attacks.
So this just makes it harder for the
hacker to successfully craft an attack
where can return, or manage, or direct
control of the program to the certain
known place that could be used to let
the attacker execute arbitrary code.
This one other defense against
stack buffer overflow.
When the shell code itself
is stored on the stack.
So remember if I don't do return
to libc then my return address has
to point me to some place where
the shell code lives, or is stored, and
you could write that shell code
into some area of the stack itself.
And then you can execute off the stack.
There's no legitimate reason for
us to execute instructions
that are stored on the stack.
So one thing we can do is we can
make the stack non executable.
Basically says the system is
not going to allow you to fetch
instructions from the stack area or
the stack segment.
If you do that then you
can't execute on the stack.
So your shell code
cannot be on the stack.
You have to find some other place to put
your shell code and maybe that's why you
have to try tricks, like return
to libc and things like that.
And use a library function
to transfer control to
the code that attacker ones executed.
So here I guess we talked about sort
of security is increasing assurance.
Making the attacker's
job more difficult.
And making the legitimate, in this
case here we're talking programmers,
their task somewhat easier.
So ASLR obviously is making
the attackers job more difficult because
key addresses that they need to know,
they don't know exactly where
they are in the address space.
And they can't put code on the stack and
hope to get it executed because we have
the hardware operating system says
not supposed to fetch instructions from
the stack area of the address space.
So these are techniques for
actually dealing with buffer overflows.
As we said, one makes it harder for
the attacker, by making it difficult for
him to find the right addresses, or be
able to use the stack flow shell code.